TONIGHT THAT ROD ROSENSTEIN OWES
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AN ANSWER.
JOINING US NOW FROM THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE, DEVIN
NUNES IS WITH US.
ROD ROSENSTEIN, ISN'T THIS THE
GUY THAT RECOMMENDED THE FIRING
OF COMEY, APPOINTED MUELLER,
SIGNED THE FINAL FISA WARRANT
APPLICATION, THE THIRD RENEWAL
AND THIS IS A GUY THAT LISA
PAGE, ANDREW McCABE AND JAMES
BAKER ALL TALKED ABOUT WEARING A
WIRE AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP IN
HOPES OF INVOKING THE 25th
AMENDMENT.
HE OWES US ANSWERS TO THAT.
>> HE OWES US ANSWERS.
HE'S NOT COMING TOMORROW, WHICH
SHOULD BE VERY TELLING.
THE STORY IS THAT HE POSSIBLY
WANTED TO HAVE A CUP OF COFFEE
WITH CHAIRMAN GOODLATTE.
THAT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE.
HE NEEDS TO TESTIFY UNDER OATH.
IF YOU LOOK AS THE STORY TONIGHT
BREAKING IN "THE WASHINGTON
POST," YOU HAVE McCABE AND
ROSENSTEIN FIGHTING OVER WHAT
HAPPENS AT THE AT THE TIME OF
WHEN HE WANTED TO WEAR A WIRE,
WHETHER OR NOT HE WANTED TO WEAR
A WIRE AND WHO WAS RESPONSIBLE
FOR WHAT.
CLEARLY THIS IS THE
INVESTIGATORS THAT HAVE NO ONE
WATCHING THEM AND THEY'RE
RUNNING AMUCK.
SO MUCH THAT THEY WON'T TOUGH TO
CONGRESS.
IT'S PATHETIC.
>> Sean: THEY'RE BOTH ARGUING
OVER WHO SHOULD HAVE RECUSED
THEMSELVES.
BOTH SHOULD HAVE NOW THAT WE
KNOW WHAT WE KNOW.
THE PRESIDENT SAID HE DECLASSIFY
AND SEND OUT THE UNREDACTED FISA
APPLICATIONS, THE BULK OF WHICH
THE INFORMATION CAME FROM THE
PHONY DOSSIER THAT HILLARY PAID
FOR AND THE FRAUD ON THE FISA
COURT.
WHERE ARE THOSE DECLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS THAT THE PRESIDENT
SAID HE WOULD RELEASE?
WHERE ARE THE 302s BETWEEN
STEELE AND OHR?
>> THE SAME THING IS TRUE, SEAN.
THE SAME PEOPLE THAT ARE ARGUING
TONIGHT ON THE PAGES OF "THE
WASHINGTON POST," WHETHER WHICH
ONE SHOULD RECUSE THEMSELVES.
THIS IS OVER A YEAR AGO WHEN THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL WAS APPOINTED.
THEY'RE SUPPOSEDLY ARGUING IN
FRONT OF MUELLER WHO SHOULD BE
RECUSED.
LIKE YOU SAID, THEY BOTH SHOULD
HAVE BEEN RECUSED.
THOSE SAME PEOPLE, THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL THAT WILL NOT
COME TO CONGRESS TO TESTIFY
UNDER OATH IS THE SAME PERSON
THAT IS BLOCKING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THERE BEING ABLE TO SEE
THIS INFORMATION THAT WE IN THE
CONGRESS HAVE BEEN ASKING FOR
NOW A COUPLE MONTHS FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO DECLASSIFY THEM.
THE PRESIDENT SAID I WANT THIS
IMMEDIATELY DECLASSIFIED WITHOUT
REDACTIONS AND THEN SHORTLY
AFTER THAT, THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL CONVENES A MEETING TO
CONVINCE THE PRESIDENT, WE NEED
TO HAVE THE I.G. LOOK AT, THIS
THAT'S WHERE WE STAND RIGHT NOW
WITH DECLASSIFICATION.
THIS IS A WHOLE NEW ESCALATION.
>> Sean: CAN'T TAKE 18 MORE
MONTHS, CONGRESSMAN.
>> IT'S RIDICULOUS, SEAN.
>> Sean: I AGREE WITH YOU.
>> I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
I.G.
I WANT IT DECLASSIFIED.
>> Sean: I AGREE WHOLE
HEARTEDLY.
A SECOND -- A REAL SPECIAL
COUNSEL OUGHT TO BE APPOINTED.
THE FBI DIRECTOR SAYING TODAY HE
WON'T SAY WHETHER OR NOT THE
PRESIDENT IS BEING WIRETAPPED
TODAY?
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
>> I MEAN, YEAH.
I DON'T KNOW -- SOME OF THAT
QUESTIONING GOES IN LITTLE
DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS.
LET'S GO BACK TO THE MAIN POINT
HERE THAT WE REALLY NEED TO KNOW
AT THE START OF THE SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR, SPECIAL COUNSEL,
WHEN REMEMBER, PEOPLE ARE LOSING
SIGHT OF THIS, THAT THE CHIEF
INVESTIGATORS AT THE TIME HAD NO
EVIDENCE OF TRUMP CAMPAIGN
COLLUDING WITH RUSSIANS.
AND SO WHY DO WE HAVE A SPECIAL
COUNSEL IN THE FIRST PLACE?
>> Sean: LOOKS LIKE LISA PAGE